now your Drake & Josh co-star Josh Peck
just got married did you go to the
wedding
um no I didn't go what did you think
about Drake's tweets and he didn't get
invited he was very missed I don't know
um I'm just happy for Josh I hope he has
a good marriage it's exciting it's just
like crazy to me that so much times fast
like so many of my friends and people
that want to go any when they are
married now it's crazy so nice I think
it makes everyone feel yeah a little bit
that everyone keeps in touch me it's
hard in his career you know you're
together like a family that everyone
goes their separate ways
yeah I really only um you know see them
once in a while so I'm going to Drake's
birthday um in a few days and like three
days yeah what are you looking forward
to most about today finally um just
getting to see the movie my mom's here
with me and it's just always so much fun
and all the people dressed up as minions
I know my friends niece is gonna be
excited because she thinks they're real
so she's gonna be like all she wanted
was to meet a minion so he was right can
you do a minion impression um okay well
they say hello which is just hello
pretty good I thought yours is better
honestly
yours was better you crushed it thank
you Miranda good thank you have a good
day